a couple of days ago I had my first
panic attack in probably a year
and to be honest I've been in two minds about
whether or not I even share that
because I don't wanna bring down the vibes
I definitely don't want sympathy
and I know that I'm so blessed in so many ways
it just feels wrong to complain
But mental health is funny like that
and I think it was a reminder to me that
healing is not linear
we have good days and we have bad days
but we share it with someone
we cry without shame when we need to
and we try again tomorrow
this evening was one of my first child free
nights in a really long time
all I felt like doing was going out into my garden
grounding my energy
spending some time with my husband
having a cheeky drink and
sowing some plans for tomorrow
I don't know if it's just me
but the world feels pretty heavy at the moment
and if you're sensitive and you already have stuff going on
it can feel like a lot
So take time when you need it
and invest it into the things that make you feel good